[Music]
welcome to session 68 in the worlds of
speculative fiction series this time
around we are going to begin the first
part of our examination of Kim Stanley
Robinson's Mars Trilogy with a little
bit more in the second session and that
is red Mars green Mars and blue Mars uh
you know a very long scope and as you
can tell quite dense set of books right
here
we may be supplementing in the next
session this series with some of the
short stories from the Martian and what
we're going to be doing this time around
is just looking at these first two books
in the trilogy which is already quite a
lot so we've got red Mars and green Mars
both of which are chronicling the
colonization and the development of Mars
not just as you could say the typical
sci-fi place where you know either
everything is turned into something
Earth-like right away or it remains
totally alien and foreign but rather
it's uh you could say terraformed or
aerial formed as they're going to call
it in the book in a vast very
complicated set of stages and steps and
mishaps and accidents now I I should
mention before we go on too much about
that so if you're new to the worlds of
speculative fiction you're wondering
what this is this is a series that
started back in 2016 originally as a
face-to-face set of lecture discussions
talks with people at the Brookfield
Public Library which was hosting it and
featuring it as a monthly series and
we've been looking at narrative worlds
in speculative fiction ever since then
we took a little pause when covid
started and then we went to this new
online format which really isn't that
new anymore and what we do is I present
for about you know 90 minutes sometimes
we go a little bit longer I'm guessing
we probably may go longer with these
we'll see what happens and I talk about
the World building that goes into the
narrative universe of the author we
typically talk if it's the first time
we're looking at the author about their
biography and we look at some of the
things that they say about their own
writing sometimes we look at reviews of
their their writing the you know
particularly the series or the books and
we also look at Key philosophical themes
that are either sort of built into the
novels or short stories or whatever it
is that we're looking at or that are
right there front and center being
worked out and discussed by the author
and their characters in the works and
with Kim Stanley Robinson I would say
it's much more the latter than it is the
former
I will say several other things before
we get fully underway so this series was
as many others have been a suggestion
and then something that was voted in by
my viewers subscribers people who follow
me in social media and it wasn't
something that was originally on my
radar but I'm actually very happy as I
typically am
um you know with the recommendations
that people have made because this is a
really interesting
thought-provoking albeit rather dense
series that I think not everybody might
get into but I I certainly have gotten
into it so for for whoever it was a
couple years back who is suggesting I
should do this and then the people who
voted for it
um thanks very much for that I'm glad
that I finally got around to it this
month and then the coming month where
we'll be discussing blue Mars and
perhaps some of uh the Martian stories
as well I should point out that these
are pretty dense books so if you haven't
read them this one is 572 Pages green
Mars is even longer coming in at uh 600
and
24 pages blue Mars is actually even
longer at uh
here we go
761 Pages presumably if he'd written you
had another one like you know pick
another color yellow orange purple black
white gray brown it would have come in
even longer because that was the the
tendency
um they are kind of a slog at first
there's a lot of characters a lot of
things going on it's quite complex plots
but I I think that it's actually quite
well worth working your way through if
only for the imaginative scope uh the
depth of the tail as well in the
handling not just of scientific matters
in a variety of different let's call
them domains but also you know coming
across in the social sciences and then
getting into let's call it the
humanities and religion and and matters
like that and existential commitments on
the parts of the characters and
projections about what you know humanity
is going to be like uh 30 40 50 60 70
years from now there's so much that is
is built into this so uh with no further
Ado we may as well get started I think
that with with this the very first thing
that we want to do is give you a taste
of the World building that is going on
in these two books and in the series as
a whole
so we obviously and I I mean obviously
for me and for anybody else who has in
fact read their way through these Works
uh because it might not be quite so
obvious to somebody who hasn't we
obviously want to spend some time on
World building at the start because that
is really a central feature of these
Works in a rather unusual way but we
also don't want to go too deep into it
because we could easily consume the
entire time for this discussion in doing
that and there's many other things that
we need to get to some biography some of
Kim Stanley Robinson's Reflections on
his own work some uh you know
philosophical themes and other things
about World building that we'll get to
but suffice it to say World building
World building is always important for
science fiction fantasy horror things
like that but it it takes on an
additional depth with these in part
because they are quite literally the
characters
building a new world they are
colonizing and transforming Mars itself
this vast planet in our solar system
that you know we're able to reach out to
and and land on Even in our own time
we've you know we've got
Landers that have explored bits of Mars
and things like that in this case though
the goal is to take Mars and
terraform it turn it into a place that
could be habitable for human beings and
not just human beings but all sorts of
other things from Earth animals plants
fungi you know single-celled organisms
of All Sorts so the goal is first to get
there and survive and start to develop a
you know new uh scientifically
oriented society that will carry out all
of these these processes and very
quickly as we're going to see what's
going on on earth and the ways in which
we human beings tend to organize things
or be organized ourselves is going to
massively impact Mars and so you know
the World building here is not just
telling us about you know places that
they go or or what it's like for them
it's also charting out
how these things are changing and
deliberately so
for the characters the people who are
involved and the the lifespan of some of
the characters can be quite long some of
the original 100 colonists these
scientists who trained for years and
years they
um have their lives most of them if they
haven't died already
extended by some uh processes that allow
their their DNA to be essentially you
know not broken down the way that it
typically is in the aging process and
their lives extended quite far which is
going to provoke some serious issues
which we'll we'll let's put those off
for a little while so what is the World
building that's going on Kim Stanley
Robinson is imagining something that you
know we've been talking about a lot in
our own time and let's say not just
talking about but dreaming about the
colonization of the solar system and you
know that is probably going to start
with with Mars Venus seems pretty tough
and inhospitable Mercury so close to the
Sun
I don't know if we're ever going to
colonize gas giants like Jupiter and
Saturn and you know we might send
something way way the hell out to these
these outer planets or you know the
asteroid belt or something like that but
Mars seems to be the place where
humanity is going to start if we in fact
ever do get around to it and in these
works that is precisely what happens it
begins with a joint
um
you know what what do we want to call it
Expedition which includes a uh a whole
bunch of Americans with a few other
people thrown in there and a whole bunch
of Russians and they are you know
sending these people on this this
massive Voyage with all of these
supplies and all of this knowledge and
training into a new environment which
now here's where the World building does
come in Kim Stanley Robinson
describes all of these things in terms
of geography
and chemistry physics biology
the developments of ecosystems uh all
the different things that are going on
within Mars itself
reservoirs of of water Frozen typically
all sorts of deposits of important
minerals volcanic activity and the human
beings get there and they begin to build
they begin to transform they begin to
develop this new world which goes from
being originally I mean these These are
titles are deliberately chosen red to
being green to being a place where the
atmosphere is being developed and
interestingly I should point out too
there's a word that comes up over and
over again in there and it's even going
to apply to Earth later on
there's a discussion about whether it's
really terraforming or whether it is
area forming air Aries is Mars right
Mars is the Latin aerys is the Greek and
so
um the question here is well what is
actually happening and this is where the
human initiative we could say comes in
and human Affairs so the World building
isn't just a you know traditional tale
of the Bold scientists transforming this
environment and here's all of its
features and they've got a nice plan no
it's much more complicated than that
because human beings are complicated as
hell as well right so there's already
discussions early on uh spurred by this
guy are Katie but also uh carried forth
by hiroko one of the other main
characters who's in charge of uh you
know play and and that aspect of of you
know developing growth and uh
winds up having a sort of cult develop
around her as does Arcadia to a certain
extent and they're proposing and many of
the other people are thinking about this
as well that
there's already sort of like a mission
laid out you need to do this and this
and this
but they're not going to
some people are going to stick to the
plan others are going to develop a new
society and there's going to be lots of
different kinds of inputs after that
coming from Earth including at the very
beginning a stowaway somebody who's not
even supposed to be there who will later
find out in green Mars it calls himself
and is called coyote right uh you know
sort of a trickster fellow who hiroko
managed to smuggle on board with a lot
of work being required on her part to do
that and you know Mars is going to end
up being colonized by a vast variety of
different peoples cultures
organizations companies are going to
play a major role in this as well as
countries we see transnationals turn
into meta Nationals and be being you
know heavily involved in in what's going
on there the UN kind of goes in and out
of existence there's all sorts of other
things that are happening many countries
are going to be uh sending their their
people up to Mars there's people who are
going there just to make money and then
come back
and all of this involves not just the
transformation and and you know some
conflict and some deliberation about how
Mars is going to be
transmuted from red to green and
ultimately to Blue it it also involves
people arguing with each other people
proposing how things ought to go
corporations trying to suck as much
resources out of it and take them to
Earth people on Mars after especially
after new generations are being born on
Mars saying Mars for the Martians Mars
for for us people so that all of this
you could say is involved in the world
building that uh Kim Stanley Robinson is
carrying out and interestingly
all of the depicted action is taking
place on Mars
I take that back there is you know some
very very early on uh discussion about
like getting into the rockets and taking
off and all of that sort of stuff and
training uh at the um you know the uh uh
Antarctic base uh to get ready for it
but actually The Story begins in media
rests in the middle of things with a
part called Festival night
which you know takes place after people
have already been there and been
building for for quite a long time and
then we start getting the rest of the
story so
um what we've got is not a a linear
development but a very complex braided
set of developments taking place on Mars
uh massively influenced by what is
happening on Earth and Earth is getting
worse and worse the environmental
problems are getting worse the political
problems are intensifying conflict
between nations and between companies
corporations is happening as well and
another thing that destabilizes matters
that we're going to talk about again a
little bit more later on is the
longevity treatments that
primarily benefit those who have the
wealth to be able to partake in them and
then the rest of Humanity on Earth
realizes that they've been shut out from
this amazing you know possible future
that the rich and the upper middle class
and the the developed countries as
opposed to developing countries are able
to afford and enjoy and use to massively
extend their power and reach and life so
all of this we could say is part of the
World building that is happening Through
The Eyes of all of these characters that
Kim Stanley Robinson has set up many of
which are killed off in the process but
many of which are able to continue on
all the way to the end of the final
crisis in green Mars I should mention
too one other thing so red Mars ends
with a massive Revolution and crisis on
Mars which entails
breaking a space elevator this massive
you know construction that winds up
falling on Mars and devastating large
amounts of of property in greenmars it
ends in something like a revolution as
well something else going on so we've
got geography we've got uh human
colonization and and you know how we
transform things we've got politics and
economics and culture and all of these
things are being drawn
imaginatively from the world that you
and I currently inhabit of course of
course you know these books are are not
written right here in our own present
right red Mars 1993 so there's a lot of
projection going on but
you know on the whole it is an alternate
history at this point but it's not that
alternate perhaps
and I think there's there's you know a
lot to recommend this incredible World
building that is going on here you could
say Kim Stanley Robinson is showing a
lot of other people how to do it on so
many different levels all at once
because Kim Stanley Robinson is a new
author to the series worlds of
speculative fiction and since we're
going to be doing two sessions one right
after the other on the Mars Trilogy we
should spend a bit of time doing you
know some biography I don't want to go
into this too deeply because I don't
want to devote too much time I want to
get into all the other things instead
but it's it's worth knowing something
about the guy and he is a living author
very involved in discussions in the
present particularly around big sweeping
themes like where are we going as a
species and where are we taking all the
other species with us in the
anthropocene right where we're you know
at risk of severely damaging this planet
as far as human life goes and other
kinds of life so where did all this come
from
Kim Stanley Robinson is born in 1952 in
Waukegan Illinois not too far from where
I'm shooting this video but his family
moves out to Southern California where
he's going to spend a lot of time and is
is still more or less you know within
that that grand region when he's only
three years of age he's the older of two
boys his father was an electrical
engineer and a project manager
working on defense projects his mother
was a teacher and she instilled in them
as you know something I can kind of
relate to my mom was also big on
promoting reading development of the
mind and so they read to him frequently
and one of the things that's very very
important is a total side note that we
know from psychological research is if
you want to produce kids who are actual
readers reading book not just reading
things on a screen well then you not
only need to read to them you not only
need to Foster reading but they need to
see you reading as well and doing so not
just for a job but for enjoyment as
something that you want to do and his
family did in fact according to Kim
Stanley Robinson model that and so he
will say and this is coming from his his
website I was always in love with
reading much more so than with TV or
movies or other media I like to read
books and read them at a prodigious rate
so he's absorbing a lot of information
and he talks about his mother in
particular it sounds like this is more
his mother's idea than his father's who
was kind of going along with this
he says she believed that physical
activity mental activity and musical
activity were all three equally
important and gave equal uh weight to
them that meant that academics American
Sports and high school band were
important and he was involved in all
three and what he calls a balanced life
which I think is a very valuable thing
that they passed along to me and you
know he goes through middle school high
school then goes off and enrolls at
University of California San Diego
1974 he earns a bachelor's in literature
English literature in 1975 so pretty
quick succession he earns an M.A in
English from Boston University out on
the east coast and then in 1978 while
he's engaging in his PhD studies at UC
San Diego working in interestingly with
Frederick Jameson who if you know your
critical theory knows a very important
person in American
reinterpretation of that particularly
with respect to literature and so in in
1978 he moves to Davis California taking
a break from his grad studies and he
works in a bookstore Orpheus books as a
Bookseller now
that's not just having a job for
somebody like Jameson and I'm reminded
this is going down memory lane uh or not
Jameson but uh Robinson of a guy who I
knew when I was in graduate school who
with another person started a bookstore
and it was the place to go for any sort
of interesting Theory and you know
offbeat movies and stuff like that and
uh you know that was the sort of place I
asked him why did you start a bookstore
and he's like so I could read books so
being a book seller especially at that
time when there wasn't such a emphasis
on let's let's make a ton of money right
could be a a great opportunity to spend
time reading and talking with other
people that are interested in that he
also started teaching and he was uh
primarily doing you know freshman ret
comp classes writing classes at
University of California Davis and then
he uh completes his his PhD doing his
dissertation in 1982 on interestingly
enough Philip K dick and he produces
this uh you know study of the novels of
Philip K dick and who got him into that
Friedrich Jameson and Jameson
was somebody who you know thought that
at that time dick was somebody well
worth studying quite correctly and so
that's what Robinson did and he said
that uh it was through that that he
really discovered the possibilities for
science fiction he says despite all this
childhood reading I'd never known that
science fiction existed I discovered it
late but found a tremendously absorbing
to me it was the best possible way to
describe how my youth in Orange County
had felt that kind of Future Shock so my
undergraduate career was kind of a
two-track thing where I did the standard
undergraduate work but I did a complete
education in science fiction in about
three years and then when I started
writing short story they were science
fiction short stories without any
conscious decision so he begins writing
and developing his his craft then he
meets his wife Lisa and they will start
a important partnership he meets her in
the 1970s when she was going to
University of California Davis and he
was teaching halftime writing half time
and she finishes her PhD in
environmental chemistry and they go to
Zurich Switzerland
because she's offered a post-doc
post-doctoral research post and uh he
says well I took the opportunity for
this to quit teaching and in 1985 I
began writing full time now before that
he's already got several books coming
out the wild Shore part of the Orange
County Series in 1984 ice hedge also in
1984 before going to Zurich they did
some traveling going to Egypt Greece and
Nepal doing hiking in the Himalayas and
that's going to furnish him with
material for for later work
he's also going to publish the memory of
whiteness a scientific romance in 1985
and then the blind geometer in 1986 and
so they're there in Zurich until 1987
and then Lisa gets a job with the Food
and Drug Administration in Washington DC
and that's where uh David their son is
born
um
then they go to Davis and they join a
co-housing community at least for a
while and Lisa began a job with the U.S
Geological Survey at their office in
Sacramento and I think that you know you
can see a lot of geological things being
reflected in the the story about Mars in
these books and then as a full-time
writer but also a stay-at-home dad
taking care of their kids for a while he
brings out a whole series of novels I'm
only going to talk about the novels not
the short stories the Gold Coast also
part of the Orange County trilogy
in 1988 green Mars a short uh uh you
know piece there not not exactly the
same thing as the green Mars that we're
thinking about here uh in 1988 and then
Pacific Edge in 1990 finishing the
Orange County series then there's a
short sharp shock uh in 1990 down and
out in the year 2000 1992. it's kind of
interesting to you know be a somebody
who's projecting into the near future
like Philip K dick did too right I mean
Blade Runner is long past us for when it
was originally supposed to happen
predicting things you know eight years
in the future is uh kind of a tricky
Endeavor going on now we get to the
actual Mars series red Mars 1993 blue
Mars 1996 in between Antarctica coming
out in 1997 uh and yeah red we've got
all these at that time then the Martians
another
um
installation a bunch of short stories
kind of scattered over this timeline all
right in 1999 and then we get the years
of rice and salt situated in a different
narrative Universe uh in 2009 Robinson
is going to be an instructor at the
Clarion Workshop teaching other people
uh how to think about these things
Galileo's dream comes out in 2009 as
well 2010 he's the guest of honor at the
68th World science fiction convention in
Melbourne and in 2011 two important
things happened he presents at this
rethinking capitalism Conference held in
University of California Santa Cruz and
discusses the cyclical nature of
capitalism among other things Robinson
is very much a theorist of where we're
going to go in Social organization in
the future he's also appointed as a mere
environmental fellow in
2011 by John Moore college and at San
Diego and then he brings out a whole
succession of other novels 2312 in 2012
now projecting 300 years in the future
Shaman a novel of the Ice Age Aurora in
2015 New York 2140 in 2017. you start to
see kind of a common theme here about
projecting into the future red moon in
2018 and the ministry for the future in
2020 and you know Robinson as I
mentioned is quite active and engaged in
a lot of discussions and presentations
so this biography is of course
incomplete but at least it gives us some
sense about how he winds up getting into
the writing of these novels the writing
the research the reflection all the
conversations that take place so that's
a good summary of what's going on there
Kim Stanley Robinson has given an
incredible variety and number of
interviews over the years and continues
to do so in the present so I thought it
would be useful to call out some bits
from five of them that have to do with
this this series in particular and the
idea of colonizing and terraforming Mars
and touch on some other important issues
in his craft and World building and you
could say his vocation
as a novelist and through that as an
activist or at least argument maker of
sorts so we begin with an interview with
the Los Angeles Review of Books
he's asked when you're working on your
books do you treat it as a World
building exercise in which the world has
its own Dynamics or does the story call
the world into beings a key question
right about the to use the tropes that
have been applied to Tolkien and to
George R Martin in terms of fantasy the
architect versus The Gardener sort of
idea and Kim Stanley Robinson says I
think more the latter but my story ideas
are often somehow World building ideas
at least this was true with the Mars
Trilogy if the story is Mars is
terraformed over a few centuries then
this is a big problem for the novel as a
form dealing with the centuries but also
a big opportunity so I would say that my
ideas often concern a group of people
dealing with a landscape somehow even
the solar system as a landscape and thus
both parts of it come into play at once
so I couldn't say which comes first and
then the follow-up question in many of
your books
things like the weather or the geology
of a situation get equal attention
alongside whatever is at stake between
the characters and sometimes even more
attention it is as if you had shifted
the novel's attention to a whole other
series of relationships do you think
this is a just just an aspect of the
novel that had not but much been
explored before or do you think you're
bringing something into the form from
other kinds of writing and his response
is I think there's always been a kind of
Novel that explores the relationships
between people and nature or a physical
situation and Challenge and I've always
been interested in these novels as a
reader going back to my childhood so
almost every novel has people as the
central characters but sometimes the
antagonist is a natural situation or the
setting is not antagonistic exactly but
extremely interesting thus Robinson
Caruso which naturally I liked and then
I'm remembering James Ramsey almonds
novels about climbing the Matterhorn or
even Huckleberry Finn in the way the
river is a major presence in the novel
The Third major character so to speak or
simply a dominant setting also William
golding's pincher Martin and really all
his first four novels and so on
the more I think about it the more I
realize that these moments describing
people in the world stick out for me
even in novels that are mostly social in
test of the ubervilles for instance
tests working uh the fields on the Moors
was for me the most striking passage
then in science fiction this often
translates into the planetary romance
where the interest again is in people
dealing with a new landscape
I always love this kind of sci-fi and
Jack Vance early Le Guin Edgar pinghorn
Frank Herbert's Dune
certain early John Brunner and really
the whole sub-genre of the planetary
romance these were among my favorite
sci-fi novels that's one of the reasons
my Mars novels took up so much of my
writing career
so he goes on he says I also took an
interest in George Stewart's
experimental novels where a natural
situation or process was made the
protagonist of the story as in storm or
fire this is also so much true of Earth
abides and his other novel centered on
an inhuman process oral's exam these
books of his tended to convince me that
people were the necessary centers of
novels but they were like limit cases
that established how far you could take
things so not only were these the kinds
of novels that were capturing me most
but all along I've spent a lot of time
hiking in the Sierra Nevadas and earlier
in my life in other mountain ranges too
and these experiences have been the most
profound in my life they are what I like
to do and when backpacking weather
really matters in a way it doesn't down
in Civilization it impacts that very day
that our you live in it this has always
struck me as worth writing about and
it's something to bring to my novels
that is out of my life rather than my
reading so I've tried to find stories
where these experiences could be put to
use and I think you can say that that
certainly is the case in these novels
isn't it
in another interview with brown study
this is recorded by the the writer of
that blog he says uh that that you know
research whether it be of the primary or
secondary variety has become an integral
element in Robinson's writing during the
last decade while writing the just
completed epic Mars terraforming Trilogy
red Mars green Mars and blue Mars
Robinson seems to have done everything
short of actually visiting the red
planet itself and then here's where he
quotes Robinson there are some very
evocative stereopticon pictures of the
Martian surface taken from the Viking
Landings the first time I got one of
these pairs of photos to resolve I was
amazed because there was a surface all
filled with humps and Hollows to the
nearby Horizon which is very close the
history of the Martian surface is
different from Earth's because nothing's
been worn down by water or plate
tectonic movement it's just an ancient
surface that has been hammered by
meteors
then I went to meteor crater with my
family down in Flagstaff Arizona and
that affected me very much because
that's a well-preserved meteor crater
like those that Park the surface of Mars
he goes on and he says there's guys in
the Smithsonian Institute in the air and
space museum who were involved with
mapping with Mars and there's an expert
on terraforming in Britain who's
basically an amateur scientist who's
done a lot of work on it and he and a
few other writers in Britain were always
on call as well these were the people
who were helping Robinson right the
topic was ripe for someone to tell a
story about it because the real science
that's been done about it had never been
Unleashed before so I was in a good
situation in that regard
then
moving to how long the process actually
took he said
there was a sort of feedback loop
between researching and writing I
learned more in between the publication
of red Mars and green Mars there were
some very important books that came out
McKay himself published a cover article
in nature on the terraforming of Mars
that really transformed that into a
scientifically respectable question it
was a heavy routine of reading
researching and writing it's what I like
to do with my days it's my work I spend
everyday writing devoting some part of
the day to writing and once I get in the
groove it's what I like to do
it was supposed to be a three-year
project so that basically doubled but
there was no helping it I'd taken on a
lot more than I thought when I started
writing it I'd wanted it to be a big
novel a door stopper a thousand page
book I'd gotten about 200 pages in and
they hadn't even arrived on Mars yet I
talked it over with my wife at that
point some other friends editors and my
agent and realized that well we're
looking at a science fiction Trilogy
which is something I always resisted
writing now much later in that interview
he said something very interesting
from my education in the literary
tradition what I liked the most was a
certain Clarity of expression the
obscurities of certain modernisms I
never appreciated there's a certain
power to Clarity of expression I think
of it as a personal preference but it
also does speak to an audience that
doesn't have to have special training in
literature they don't have to be English
Majors I think of Gabriel Garcia Marquez
in that respect because American novels
were very convoluted and difficult and
there were people like John Bart and
Vladimir nabikov talking about the death
of literature and the exhaustion of
literature and that there were no
stories to be told anymore
I think when the translation of 100
Years of Solitude hit in 1973 It just
knocked the stuffing out of those guys
it's obvious for Marquez you can still
tell a story in straightforward language
that is incredibly powerful
now he goes out and he says it was also
at UC
SD University of California uh Davis
right that Robinson first encountered
the Marxist theory that coupled with
Robinson's ecological concerns would
inform the thematic and political
content of Robinson's work and he says
Friedrich Jamison was one of my academic
advisors in school he comes from a more
traditional 50s sartree and existential
Marxism that has to do with politics and
personal freedom he taught me a lot
about political Theory because that's
his angle on literature he tends to
subsume the environment underneath the
notion of a socialist or Marxist
government that if you truly want to be
environmentalist you have to end up
being a socialist anyway in order to get
there and this is going to play a really
important role sometimes in terms of
characters and what they're doing
sometimes in terms of the last attack or
loss of that in these novels he goes on
and he says
I've been thinking about Utopias for a
long time and looking at the world that
we live in and the discrepancy between
the two is fairly acute so I think about
politics a fair amount as much as anyone
can stand to but I think the
environmental concern it's a chicken and
egg argument which is more important
although it seems the environment is the
real reality that we have to adjust to
in the political systems we make up are
there just to get us in the right
balance with the environment so I don't
have the same fix on it as Jameson does
now talking about some of his characters
he says it's very easy for me to
flip-flop between the and and sax these
are two important points of view points
of view because depending on what I'm
focusing on at the moment I can really
believe in one or the other of them
pretty enthusiastically but this is what
makes me a novelist rather than a
preacher or a philosopher
incoherence is not an altogether bad
thing and a novelist if you can sort out
the strands and express them clearly it
means you can be even-handed towards
characters and let them speak in their
own mind and at a certain point Ann and
sax take on these lives of their own
working hard on these books I could get
to a state where it was like taking down
telephone messages and being a medium
about it and I feel that Anne and sax
have their own integrity at this point
and that's a lovely feeling that's part
of what makes novel writing so nice
in the public books interview
he's uh being asked about Mars Mars has
been undergoing a Renaissance lately
between the publication of Andy Weirs
the Martian in 2011. NASA's recent
discovery of evidence of flowing water
under the planet's surface and George
R.R Martin's collection of old Mars
stories in 2015 in which he laments that
the real Mars was simply not as
interesting as its pulp predecessor how
is the meaning of Mars changed for you
in the years since the publication of
your trilogy so Robinson says this
I would disagree with George about that
the real Mars is way more interesting
than the pulp Mars which was just a
fantasy space often swapped out with
Venus or whatever and we can have both
now in effect because we still export a
lot of Dreams there to Mars I think Mars
is a great place to think about Earth as
a planet and about society as a
constructed thing we're still working on
with the idea we could improve it in
specific Martian terms the idea that
there might still be bacterial life on
Mars was not there when I wrote my Mars
books and that is a game changer if we
take it seriously also the presence of
perchlorates in the soil poisonous to
humans and the relative lack of nitrogen
on Mars are new findings that really
complicate the idea of inhabiting the
planet and terraforming it they're not
deal breakers but they're significant
obstacles however even if slower
terraforming Mars remains a great
long-term goal but law long-term meaning
like 10 000 years which means we have to
get our relationship to our own planet
in order for anything to happen on Mars
he's then asked well given your interest
in questioning the future of
interstellar travel how do you weigh the
massive Investments necessary for
developing Technologies for spatial
Exploration with the need for investment
in so many other less fantastic but
equally important research aspirations
here's what Robinson says
the main project for Civilization now is
creating a sustainable way of life here
on Earth that's the necessary First Step
anything beyond would rely on that
succeeding so exploring space is less
important now that said space science is
an earth science what we learn around
the solar system can often illuminate
the project we have here of keeping this
planet's biosphere healthy so I like the
space program and I feel it's not funded
out of proportion to its importance
robotic missions are already doing a lot
of what we need done but humans are
better at many things than robots and
it's exciting to see humans on the other
planets more than it is to see robots so
on balance I'd like to see more
investment in space science and less in
areas like weaponry our taxpayer bailout
of the banker gamblers who lost their
bets in 2008 cost us about 10
000 times the entirety of what we've
spent on NASA
so you know very interesting set of
proposals there on his part in the
building blog he is asked I'm interested
in the possibility of that literary
genres might have to be redefined in
light of climate change in other words a
novel where two feet of fall snow falls
on Los Angeles or sand dunes creep
through the suburbs of Rome would be
considered a work of Science Fiction
even surrealism today but that same book
in 50 years time could very well be a
work of climate realism so to speak so
if climate change is making the word
surreal World surreal
then what it means to write a realistic
novel will have to change as a science
fiction novelist how does that affect
how you approach your work and here's
what Robinson says
I've been saying that for a number of
years that we're now all living in a
science fiction novel together a book we
co-write
a lot of what we're experiencing now is
unsurprising because we've been prepped
for it by science fiction but I don't
think surrealism is the right way to put
it surrealism is so often a matter of
Dreamscapes of things becoming more than
real and as a result more Sublime you
might think for example of J.G Ballard's
the drowned world and the way in which
he sees these giant catastrophes as a
release from our current social setup
catastrophe and disaster are
aestheticized and looked at as a
miraculous salvation from our present
reality but it wouldn't really be like
that
I started writing about Earth's climate
in climate change in the Mars books I
needed something to happen on Earth that
was shocking enough to allow a kind of
historical Gap in which my martians
could realistically establish
Independence I'd already been working
with Antarctic scientists who were
talking about the West Antarctic ice
sheet and how unstable it might be and
so I use that discussed in green Mars
and in blue Mars I showed a flooded
London but after you get past the
initial dislocations and disasters what
you've got is another landscape to be
inhabited another situation that would
have its own architecture its own
problems its own Solutions
the Blogger asks Mars has a long history
as a kind of utopian destination and in
that year Mars Trilogy is no exception
what is it about Mars that brings out
this particular kind of speculation
Robinson says
it brings up an unusual modern event
that can happen in our mental Landscapes
which is comparative planetology that
wasn't really available to us before the
modern era really until Viking
one thing about Mars is that it's a
radically impoverished landscape you
start with nothing the bare rock the
volatile chemicals that are needed for
Life some water and an empty landscape
that makes it a kind of gigantic
metaphor or modeling exercise and it
gives you a way to imagine the
fundamentals of what we're doing here on
Earth
I find it's a very good thing to begin
thinking that we are terraforming Earth
because we are
and we've been doing it for quite some
time we've been doing it by accident and
mostly by damaging things in some ways
there have been improvements in terms of
human support systems but there's still
so much damage damage that's gone
unacknowledged or ignored even when all
along we knew it was happening people
kind of shrug and think yeah there's
nothing we can do about it or maybe the
next generation will be clever enough to
figure it out so on we go
Mars is an interesting platform where we
can model these things but I don't know
that we'll get there for another 50
years or so and once we do get there I
think that for many many years maybe
many decades it will function like
Antarctica does now it will be an
interesting scientific base that teaches
us things and it's beautiful and
charismatic but not important in the
larger scheme of human history on Earth
it's just an interesting place to study
that we can learn things from they says
but if you think of yourself as
terraforming Earth and you think about
sustainability
then you can start thinking about
permaculture and what permaculture
really means it's just not sustainable
agriculture but a name for a certain
kind of History
because the word sustainability is now
code for let's make capitalism work over
the Long Haul without ever getting rid
of the hierarchy between rich and poor
and without establishing social justice
sustainable development as well that's a
term that's been contaminated it doesn't
even mean sustainable anymore it means
let us continue what we're doing but
somehow get away with it by some magic
waving of the hands or some techno
Silver Bullet suddenly you can make it
all right to continue in all our current
habits
and yet it's not just that our habits
are destructive they're not even
satisfying to the people who get to play
in them so there's a stupidity involved
at the cultural level
finally we have this great wire
interview
retrospective he's asked Mr Robinson 30
years ago you wrote the Mars Trilogy of
science fiction series about colonizing
Mars that won popularity all over the
world what would you say today is travel
to Mars science now or is it still
fiction
Kim Stanley Robinson answers that
depends on the time Horizon we're
talking about it's theoretically
conceivable for us to send a manned
spaceship to Mars in the next 100 years
but in Practical terms it's impossible
first of all it would fall down on the
cost The Colony on Mars would cost about
500 billion dollars the next hurdle is
getting there at the present time it's
expected to take nine months nine months
without gravity would have disastrous
effects on our body our muscles and bone
structure deteriorate without pressure
then he's asked if you get into a
spaceship at the age of 40 you land nine
months later on Mars as a physical
geriatric he says well the process could
be combated with intensive training as
practiced by today's astronauts who sit
on an ergo meter for four hours a day
however we know now that there are also
chemical processes involved that damage
the heart the solution would therefore
be the old sci-fi idea of creating
artificial Gravity by rotation but we
haven't gotten that far yet
and then he's asked well let's assume we
get to Mars in good health what can we
expect there
it's cold between
-30 and minus 120 degrees Celsius
there's no atmosphere no gravity no
Global magnetic field only weak local
magnetic fields offering little
protection from cosmic radiation the
soil is contaminated with perchlorate in
short it's a place that's hostile to
life
for people ever to settle there the Mars
colonies would have to be built meters
under the Earth all the same Mars is
still the best candidate for
colonization there's a lot of water
though it's frozen there's carbon
dioxide likewise in the form of ice and
there's sunlight these are three
important ingredients for Life what
there's not however as far as we know is
life itself for example in the form of
bacteria that's where we humans come in
then he's asked the key word is
terraforming what does this mean
he says well the word comes from
scientific literature and describes the
attempt to create a planet Earth for
Mars that requires a highly complex
industrial process first of all there's
this thing about the toxic soil the
entire surface of Mars would have to be
sewn with a mixture of sand and bacteria
so that the highly toxic salts could be
consumed and transformed then we'd have
to cause something that we want to
prevent on Earth an artificial
greenhouse effect to release the Frozen
CO2 and warm up the climate that's the
only way to make plants grow and in turn
produce oxygen through photosynthesis
however at this point we still haven't
solved the problem that plants need
nitrogen to live but there's practically
none on Mars you see terraforming is
conceivable in theory but virtually
impossible to implement in practice
and you know he says I think martians if
you know we had them would be like super
Tibetans Tibetans have passed through an
amazing Evolution within a very short
time that enables them to increase the
supply of oxygen to their blood cells
Life on Mars could possibly be like life
at an altitude of thirty thousand
kilometers people would probably adapt
by Evolution they'd perform better but
prob possibly also be more susceptible
to certain diseases
then he's asked as well they would be
humans biologically but what about
culturally this is actually a big issue
that comes up in the the trilogy what
kind of value system would people have
moved 400 million kilometers away from
Earth have would human rights apply up
there
he says well we can only think of Mars
as a mirror of the world Mars may be
colonized in a thousand years time in
other words at a time when most of what
we believe in today capitalism for
example or democracy will no longer
function here on Earth when I describe
the colonization of Mars in my books I'm
not thinking of a distant planet but
using the idea of Mars as a metaphor for
a different Earth
how would we live how would we organize
ourselves are there Alternatives because
that's more and more difficult to
imagine in our world
I extrapolate the question into space
how would we organize ourselves on Mars
for example now I assume that we would
try to develop an alternative economic
system on Mars because what drives us
here on Earth also digs our Graves
capitalism
we are destroying our Resources with our
growth logic we would therefore need an
economic system that allows everyone to
share and that protects natural
resources and if you change the economic
system you also have to change the
education system and if you change the
schools you automatically change the
society's values and Norms so to answer
your question martians would still be
people they would have the same needs
fears and hopes that's embedded deep in
our DNA
but they would live in a completely
different culture and would therefore
have different values and basic rights
he's asked then so your answer to the
present crises is not the anti-progress
degrowth that a lot of left-wingers
advocate but a Marxism that has faith in
progress he says correct we can't turn
the clock back we have to use our
present technological capabilities to
save our world you could translate that
as we don't need to terraform a new
planet but to establish Mars colonies in
the world
islands that provide social crisis
independent Basics Now isn't that an
interesting idea so in these books are
contained and probably you could say in
a lot of Robinson's other works the
seeds for these Mars communities or Mars
places right
and then he says to sum up uh colonizing
Mars is near neither easy nor profitable
this is the interviewer nevertheless
both government and private programs
exist and we're seeing growing public
interest in the subject where does the
fascination for this planet come from
and Robinson then says well I think
there's two different reasons for it
first feasibility some of the things we
writers merely imagined 30 years ago are
now technically possible Mars is still
far away but it has come closer
technologically
but the second reason for the new
enthusiasm for Mars is pure escapism
we've run the Earth down so much that a
lot of people feel they want to seek a
new opportunity on a new planet I think
the first motive is sound and just and
the second is flawed reasoning as far as
I'm concerned we'll never be able to
leave the Earth where a product of this
Earth we have to rescue it the crisis on
Earth is acute it has to be resolved in
the next few hundred years however it
will be a thousand years before we can
colonize Mars so I don't see my science
fiction novels as space scenarios but it
has conceptual experiments that could
help us create a better world here
the last question that we'll look at
here
how will later generations look back on
our idea of wanting to colonize Mars so
Kim Stanley Robinson says they'll think
it's a senseless naive idea but people
are rarely interested in sensible ideas
and often keen on the technologically
most extreme possibility and at that
moment at this moment that's journeying
to Mars so a lot of very interesting
Reflections and speculations on the work
the process but also
how these books articulate an idea ideas
that we need here on Earth
before we launch into looking at some of
the philosophical themes that are built
into these first two novels some of
which will probably have to delay until
next time looking at the the third novel
in the series I wanted to touch on
something that could be considered a
philosophical theme could be considered
part of world and also plot and
character building and is also a matter
of what we might call the literary
construction and expression of these
works and you know since Kim Stanley
Robinson was somebody who came up within
the milieu of what we could call High
literary Theory right working with
Friedrich Jamison it makes sense to
bring in some other literary theorists
and the one that came to mind almost
immediately for me after hearing Jameson
even though there isn't like an
automatic intrinsic connection with them
is uh the the Russian theorist Mikhail
bakhtin and specifically this work
problems of dostoyevsky's Poetics which
I think might have been the work that
really put him on the radar of a lot of
Western literary theorists because one
of the things that he proposes about
Dostoyevsky
in here that I think is is a great
catchphrase and really does apply well
to this series is the notion of the
Polyphonic novel as opposed to the
monophonic so phone a means you know
voice and poly multiple mono one and the
question is can we determine uh where
the author him or herself
fits or sits in relation to the
characters and not just the characters
as such but the characters as
embodiments but also as
engaging and experimenting with ways of
life and ways of thinking and relating
to other human beings what it is that
they articulate and so you know bhaktin
talks about dostoyavsky as being you
know sort of a not the only person who's
ever done this but as being a
groundbreaker and as many of his fellow
literary theorists not having gotten
this always playing the similar thing
that they do with Shakespeare or with
other uh people who have a lot of
different characters who who represents
the author right
and it's interesting too because I think
that you can say that in some of Philip
K Dick's novels they're equally
polyphonic novels dick is not saying I
identify with this person right here
even though they might be the point of
view character think for example of Do
Androids Dream of Electric Sheep where
they're making important points and not
completely resolving their arguments in
relation to each other now the scope for
these novels is much much vaster in time
you know we're talking about centuries
really even the first novel we're
talking about you know Generations years
and years and years going on and so
there's plenty of opportunity for people
who have different points of view which
are going to be massively important in
these novels
not just to articulate them as if
they're sort of stock stand-ins or this
person is the red this person is the
green this person is this you know but
rather to
evolve their ideas at least some of the
people so I wanted to read a few
passages just a few because we're not
going to make this a video just about
park teen so
he tells us and this is very early on
that um
here we go uh he's talking about the the
problems with the literature on
Dostoyevsky and he says that an approach
on the part of the critic similar to the
uninstructed perception of readers who
are continually arguing with
dostoyevsky's characters does in fact
correspond to a basic structural feature
of dostoyevsky's Works
Dostoyevsky like good as Prometheus
creates not voiceless slaves but Free
People
capable of standing alongside their
creator capable of not agreeing with him
and of even rebelling against him this
is what he takes Dostoevsky to be doing
in his literature a plurality of
independent and unmerged voices and
consciousnesses a genuine polyphony of
fully valid voices is in fact the chief
characteristic of dostoyevsky's novels
what unfolds in his works is not a
multitude of characters and Fates in in
a single objective World illuminated by
a single authorial Consciousness rather
a plurality of consciousnesses with
equal rights in each with its own world
combined but are not merged in the unity
of the event
dostoyevsky's major heroes are by the
very nature of his Creative Design not
only objects of authorial discourse but
also subjects of their own directly
signifying discourse in no way then can
a character's discourse be exhausted by
the usual functions of characterization
and plot development nor does it serve
as a vehicle for the author's own
ideological position the consciousness
of the character is given as someone
else's Consciousness another's
Consciousness yet at the same time it is
not turned into an object is not closed
does not become a simple object of the
author's consciousness
in this sense the image of a character
in Dostoevsky is not the usual
objectified image of a hero in the
traditional novel
Dostoyevsky is the creator of the
Polyphonic novel he created a
fundamentally new novelistic genre
therefore his work does not fit any of
the preconceived Frameworks or
historical literary schemes that we
usually apply to various species of the
European novel right now he's writing
this much much earlier obviously
Robinson is is writing much later after
this is not a a new idea to us and we
can talk about many other people who
create polyphonic novels right and
bhaktin might might be wrong in saying
that Dostoevsky is the originator of
this
but I think there's something definitely
like that going on in here where we have
so many important
point of view characters whose inner
discourse
and whose arguments and uh agreements
and critiques and Reflections uh and
engagements with other people we we do
get to see and not everybody is
represented in that way there's there's
many that we could say are kind of
faceless just there for one line kind of
extras but there's there's a vast host
of quite important members of the first
hundred the first hundred to land on
Mars actually 101 because coyote has
been smuggled on board right and then
there's the children and then there's
the various immigrants who are coming in
as well and uh you know have their
different purposes and it's interesting
because you know it's not just the
people that we would say are closer to
Kim Stanley Robinson's own point of view
as a person who are you know battling it
out and getting developed we even get
people who are kind of you know sellouts
to the multinational or metanational
corporations right so they're they get
some some character development as well
in this and not everybody sees eye to
eye so I think that this is this is
quite important and they're in they're
engaged in a process that is about not
just technological issues or political
issues like what kind of society are we
going to have they're thinking about the
nature of humanity itself they're
engaged in some pretty you know
pragmatic but deep philosophical
questions we can say
now
um
I want to bring up one other uh passage
from here
he talks a little bit later about this
guy engelhardt you know finally
understanding what's going on in the
Dostoevsky and novel and he says the
hero's ideas lying at the base of this
plane in the novel are as much the
subject of representation as much here
idea Heroes as the ideas of uh Rasha
lanikov Ivan karamazov or any of the
others in no way do they become
principles of representation or
construction of the entire novel as a
whole that is principles of the author
himself as the artist if that were the
case we would have an ordinary
philosophical novel of ideas the
hierarchical emphasis or excellent given
to some of these ideas does not
transform the dostoyevskian novel into
an ordinary monologic novel which Always
and ultimately contains at heart only
one single accent from the Viewpoint of
the novel's artistic construction these
ideas are merely full and equal
participants in the action along with
the ideas of uh raskolanikov Ivan
karamazov and the others what is more
the tone for the construction of the
novel as a whole is set precisely by
these characters so he goes on and he
says thus not a single one of the ideas
of the heroes neither of the negative
nor the positive Heroes becomes a
principle of authorial representation
and none constitute the novelistic world
in its entirety this raises the question
how are the heroes worlds and the ideas
that lie at their base United with the
world of the author that is the world of
the novel right so
and it's interesting too because he
brings up you know environmental uh
concerns in that as well soil Earth
something that has to be constituted in
these or you know water particularly
think about blue Mars life soil all of
these key ideas and how are they going
to be developed now we do know that Kim
Stanley Robinson himself has some you
know well worked out evolving over time
ideas about the the possibility of
getting to Mars what Mars would
represent for us and the need to we
could say get our Collective crap
together on this planet before we
actually ruin the Earth for human life
and most other forms of life that would
preclude us even getting to anywhere
else Mars or anywhere else in the solar
system
um but you know that can be a motivating
force for a lot of the characters but
that is not that is not the one one
single driving idea for this is there
one single driving idea I think that
there isn't instead it's a constellation
of important human questions that are
really on the one hand technological or
political but on the other hand deeply
existentially philosophical and so I
wanted to begin there before we start
looking at some of these ideologies that
are developing and clashing with each
other and some of the problematics that
are being raised because I think that
that's important for understanding the
scope of this trilogy
one of the great philosophical themes
that is running through all of these
novels in the the Mars Trilogy is the
figuring out where the human race is
going and ought to be going and this
involves using human rationality one of
our basic capabilities and you could
also say human volition which is very
complicated but we have a capacity to
decide to choose to think together about
how to do things and you can't just do
it all by yourself you need to do it
with other people in communities and
this is where it gets very tricky and so
I'm going to begin here with a passage
there's a lot of different things we're
going to bring up as we explore this
early on in red Mars this is one of the
sort of italicized passages where
Robinson is not having a character speak
in their own terms but it's kind of a
bigger picture thing so it runs his
history has an inertia in the four
dimensions of space-time particle or
events have directionality
mathematicians trying to show this draw
what they call World lines on graphs in
human Affairs individual World lines
form a thick tangle curling out of the
darkness of pre-history and stretching
Through Time a cable the size of Earth
itself spiraling around the sun on a
long curved course that cable of Tangled
World lines is history
seeing where it has been it's clear
where it's going it's a matter of simple
extrapolation
but what kind of differential would it
take to escape history to escape and
inertia that powerful and carve a new
course the hardest part is leaving Earth
behind and that is indeed what the
characters are proposing struggling with
living out some successfully some
unsuccessfully producing movements
factions as a matter of fact in green
Mars there's a passage that I won't
bring up at this point where somebody
who turns out to be a really major
character in this saxophrudge or sax for
short laments the fact that there isn't
anything like you know what we think
about from Isaac asimov's Foundation
series where there's a science of human
history that can extrapolate forward
it's way Messier but that makes it much
more human and it's interesting I'll say
as a also a reflection having read
through these now several times and
going back to the early parts of red
Mars to see all the foreshadowing that
winds up taking place in who's saying
things and and the importance of the
characters
so this also is in uh early on in red
Mars in the voyage out uh Ann Claiborne
is talking about not terraforming right
that uh article 7 of the Mars treaty
seems to be forbidding terraforming that
so many people are talking about and we
get two different uh sets of responses
to this one is from arcady and our Katie
is going to be giving rise himself to an
entire movement that survives long after
he's dead bogadonavists right and so he
says I would say that we should ignore
that provision as well and why does he
say that well because just earlier he's
where they're talking about the the
treaties
um he says that you know we can decide
for ourselves there are aspects of the
treaty you haven't mentioned bases built
on Mars will belong to the countries
that build them we'll be building
American and Russian bases according to
the provision of the law and that puts
us right back into the nightmare of
Terran law and Terran history American
and Russian businesses will have the
right to exploit Mars so long as the
profits are somehow shared I don't
believe he says we should acknowledge
these Provisions for even a moment so he
is charting out a course that says we
need to decide for ourselves and he says
if you're willing to disregard one
article about terraforming you should be
willing to disregard the rest right
let's make our own history our own
course our own new Society
and then sax Russell says all these
changes are going to happen inevitably
being on Mars will change Us in an
evolutionary way and our Katie then
raises a really important Point saying
no history is not Evolution it's a false
analogy evolution is a matter of
environment and chance acting over
millions of years history is a matter of
environment and choice acting within
lifetimes sometimes within years or
months or days history is lamarkian as
opposed to darwinian right so if we
choose to establish certain institutions
on Mars there they will be and if we
choose others there they will be so he's
setting out you know a basic idea so now
we've got Anne who's saying we shouldn't
terraform she will become one of the not
necessarily leaders but certainly
Inspirations for what are called the
Reds the people who want is a minimal
interference in Martian geography as
possible adapting human being beings to
Mars rather than the opposite sax is
charting this what is going to be called
the green strategy we need to Green up
Mars uh terraform it that means bringing
in life plants lichens molds all sorts
of you know bacteria and ultimately
changing it so that it will work for
humans Arcadia is much more politically
focused saying we need to break with
Earth and our orders and the constraints
that have been laid on us and start
doing what we want to do and then we
have Phyllis
interestingly Phyllis who will become
the sellout to the transnational
meta-national corporations become
somebody who is hated by the rest of the
100 and she says you want some kind of
communal Utopia and it's not possible I
should think Russian history would have
taught you something like that and then
he says our Katie now I put to use what
it has taught me and she says advocating
an ill-defined Revolution fomenting a
crisis situation getting everybody upset
and at odds with each other
and uh you know this is also
representing an important point of view
as well the idea well we need to
accommodate ourselves to the the rulers
of Earth who are giving us what to do
a little bit later on there's this great
discussion between Anne and sax and
um you know
there's this great line that uh they're
they're arguing and this was not a reply
to Anne's point but the substitution of
another one it was an argument that was
very influential Millions on Earth
wanted to come to Mars to the New
Frontier where life was an adventure
again waiting list for immigration both
real and fake were massively over
subscribed but nobody wanted to live in
a bath of mutagenic radiation in the
Practical desire to make the planet safe
for humans was stronger in most people
than the desire to preserve the lifeless
landscape already there or protect a
postulated indigenous life that many
scientists assured them did not exist so
already sax and Anne are representing
the red and green perspective
um then we get this you know discussion
about uh
um John and Frank who you know are
important characters early on you might
actually uh wind up thinking that
they're more important until both of
them end up dying John actually because
of John Boone because of Frank and you
know they both of them give rise to
additional ideas and and stuff like that
so
um going on again we we have another key
character who's being introduced Michael
who will be there all the way through
greenmars who is the psychologist and
interestingly enough I'm going to say
this by way of digression there's even
the use of grimacion semiotic squares in
this something that you know I used to
Tinker around with a lot back in
graduate school and he is trying to work
out what the categories for people on
Mars are going to be how they're going
to change then we get to another really
important consideration with hiroko I
who by the way has smuggled coyote her
lover and friend onto board so it's not
just 100 original colonists it's 101 and
as we're going to find out nergal who
winds up becoming incredibly important
in green Mars is in fact uh Coyote's
child now
hiroko subverts the arrangements that
are met and starts doing it starts
essentially forming a cult around ideas
that she has now let's let's see what
these are
so there's a ceremony going on that
Michael is observing and she sat across
from Michael and began to chant in
Japanese evangio leaned over and
whispered a translation or rather an
explanation in his ear they were
celebrating the ariofani a ceremony
they'd created together under hiroko's
guidance and inspiration it was kind of
a landscape religion a consciousness of
Mars as a physical space infused with
Kami part of the Shinto religion brought
to Mars from Japan but the idea is
there's Kami everywhere which where the
spiritual energy or power that rested in
the land itself Kami was manifested most
obviously in certain extraordinary
objects in the landscape Stone pillars
isolated ejecta Shear Cliffs oddly
smooth crater Interiors the broad
circular peaks of the great volcanoes
these intensified expressions of Mars
Kami had a Terran analog within the
colonists themselves here we get to
another really important idea
hiroko called this idea
viriditas taking this from Hildegard of
bingen that Greening fructoparis power
within which knows the wild world itself
is Holy Kami viriditas it was the
combination of these sacred Powers which
would allow humans to exist here in a
meaningful way when Michael heard
avengia whisper the word combination all
the terms immediately fell into a
semantic rectangle Kami and veritas Mars
and Earth hatred and love absence and
yearning and then the Kaleidoscope
clicked home and all the rectangles
folded into space in his mind all
antinomies collapsed to a single
beautiful rose the heart of the
areophonic Kami suffused with viriditas
both fully read and fully green at the
same one in the same time his job was
slack his skin was burning he could not
explain it if he wanted to his blood was
fire in his veins and we see another I
mean there's a multiple references to
this in green Mars would make a lot of
sense that viriditas would be discussed
and we seek we see heroko teaching
look at the pattern this seashell makes
the dappled whirl curving towards
Infinity that's the shape of the
universe itself there's a constant
pressure pushing toward pattern a
tendency and matter to evolve into ever
more complex forms it's a kind of
pattern gravity a holy grinning power we
call viriditas and it is the driving
force in the cosmos life you see like
those sand fleas and limpets and krill
though these Krill in particular are
dead in helping the fleas like all of us
waving a hand like a dancer and because
we are alive the universe the universe
must be said to be alive we are its
Consciousness as well as our own We rise
out of the cosmos and see its mesh of
patterns and it strikes us as beautiful
and that feeling is the most important
thing at all in the universe it's
culmination like the color of the flower
at first Bloom on a wet morning it's a
holy feeling and our task in this world
is to do everything we can to Foster it
and one way to do this is to spread life
everywhere to aided into existence where
it was not before as here on Mars
this to her was the Supreme Act of love
and when she talked about it even if
they didn't fully understand they felt
the love
so this is another really important idea
isn't it that we find going on here and
it's you know one that captivates many
many people
um going on as well uh a little bit
later on in the falling into History
Section we have this character uh Jurgen
who is is from Switzerland and as it's
going to turn out a Swiss company is
going to be very important and
Switzerland is going to be important as
well in
Breaking Free of the Noose of the
earth-based
transnationals so
they asked him what he thought of the
debate between the Reds and the greens
and he Shrugged and summarized what he
could have ANS read and Sax's position
I don't think they are either right one
of them said his name was Jurgen and he
was one of the leaders and engineer who
seemed some kind of cross between a
Burgermeister and Gypsy King dark haired
and sharp faced and serious both sides
say they're in favor of nature of course
one has to say this the Reds say that
the Mars that is already here is nature
but it is not nature because it is dead
it is only rock the greens tell this and
say they will bring nature to Mars where
they're terraforming but that is not
nature either
that is only culture a garden you know
an artwork so neither way it gets nature
there isn't such a thing as nature
possible on Mars he says and then John
Boone says what do you call what you're
doing and he says we don't call it
anything it's just Mars so we have some
other perspectives coming up as well and
then we have this very interesting
discussion of the sufis who have come to
Mars and have formed entire communities
separate from the other Muslims there
and
um John is is engaging with them John
Boone and they're sort of explaining
their their lifestyle to him and and a
bunch of other things as well so here's
a little selection from that inside the
building a party of about 20 people
greeted in both men and women alike the
women were bare-headed and behaved just
like the men which again surprised John
and alerted him to the fact that things
among the sufis were different than they
were among Arabs generally he sat down
and drank coffee with them and started
asking questions again they were
cataract sufis he said pantheist
influenced by early Greek philosophy and
modern existentialism Trying by modern
science and the riyayat al-qab the
vision of the heart to become with that
alt become one with that Ultimate
Reality which was God
there are four mystical Journeys due
said to him the first begins with gnosis
and ends with fauna or passing away from
all phenomenal things the second begins
with fauna is succeeded by Baka or
abiding at this point you journey in the
real by the real to the real and you
yourself are a reality a hawk and after
that you move on to the center of the
spirit universe and become one with all
others who have done likewise
I guess I haven't begun the first
journey yet John said I don't know
anything they were pleased by this
response he could see and they go out
and explain you know that uh there's
there's all these other things going on
and they show that a gift economy is
absolutely Central and they're not just
using like ancient ideas of gift they're
also incorporating say you know the
anthropological research of a mouse uh
Marcel miles or people like that that's
going to become important as well
um passing on a little bit further
um there's discussion which we'll get to
a bit later about the in the not
immortality but longevity treatment that
might actually be a topic we discuss in
the next session on on Blue Mars here's
a a very important uh discussion that is
going on and
um
here we go so John is is being cheered
you know
um by a bunch of people and he's giving
a kind of speech as well I'm only gonna
excerpt from this he says uh what can I
say friends he says look here we are on
Mars that's our gift and a great gift it
is the reason we have to keep giving all
our lives to keep the cycle going like
an EXO Echo economics where you take
from the system where what you take from
the system has to be balanced by what
you give into it balanced or exceeded to
create all that anti-entropic surge
which characterizes all creative life
and especially the step across to a new
world this place that is neither nature
nor culture transformation of a planet
into a world and then a home now we all
know that different people have
different reasons for being here and
just as important the people who sent us
up had different reasons for sending us
and now we're beginning to see the
conflicts caused by these differences
there are storms Brewing on the horizon
meteors of trouble flying in and some of
them are going to strike dead on rather
than skip overhead it may get
ugly at times it almost certainly will
get ugly so we have to remember that
just as these meteor strikes enrich the
atmosphere the human conflicts coming
down may do the same melting the
permafrost at our social base melting
all those frozen institutions away and
leaving us with the necessity of
creation the imperative to invent a new
social order that is purely Martian as
Martian as hiroko I our own Persephone
now come back out of the regoleth to
announce the start of this new spring
and he goes on and he talks about you
know what this is going to look like and
then a little bit later
in this speech he says
the encroachment on that set of rules
has begun everywhere Like A Parasite
feeding on the edges of its host
organism because that's what the
replacement set of rules is the
replacement by the Earth people telling
Mars what to do the old parasitic greed
of the Kings and their henchmen this
system we call the transnational World
Order is just feudalism all over again a
set of rules that is anti-ecologic it
does not give back but rather enriches a
floating International Elite while
impoverishing everything else and so of
course the so-called Rich Elite are in
actuality poor as well disengaged from
real human work and therefore from real
human accomplishment parasitical in the
most precise sense and yet powerful to
his parasites that have taken control
can be sucking the gifts of human work
away from their rightful recipients
which are the seven generations and
keeping them keeping feed eating on them
while increasing the repressive powers
that keep them in place so it's
democracy versus capitalism at this
point friends and we out on this front
here Outpost of the human world are
perhaps better positioned than anyone
else to see this and Fight This Global
battle there's empty land here there's
scarce and non-renewable resources here
and we're going to get swept up into the
fight and we cannot choose not to be
part of it we are one of the prizes and
Our Fate will be decided by what happens
throughout the human world that being
the case we had better band together for
the common good for Mars and for us and
for all the people on Earth and for the
Seven Generations it's going to be hard
it's going to take years and the
stronger we are the better our chances
which why I'm so happy to see that
burning meteor in the sky pumping The
Matrix of life into our world so another
very important uh representation of
where things could be going
um there's a you know some other
interesting conversations that are
taking place throughout uh these Works
representing articulating developing
further the uh positions the ideas that
that people have and we should say that
even more important is the fact that by
the middle and the end of Green Mars we
see a truly new Society being developed
a new world being
born you could say and a lot of this is
going to have to do with opportunities
that are presented so we should talk
next not just about these positions but
about how the conflict plays itself out
long term and at certain crisis points
which allow something like revolutions
to actually take place
there are so many philosophical themes
yet to explore in this Trilogy and we'll
probably have to put off most of them to
the next session when we're going to
talk about blue Mars in particular and
perhaps some of the stories in the
Martian so some of the matters that are
coming up here will get Amplified there
but one that we cannot avoid which is
absolutely Central to the narrative in
these two is the notion of Revolution
and people throw this word around very
easily but a real Revolution is
incredibly
complicated and unpredictable there's
often a lot of collateral damage that
happens in it and we're going to talk
about one of the main sources of that in
just a minute but I wanted to call
attention to two particular passages so
this is near the end of red Mars and
Frank and Maya are talking and he's says
you know what happened
or she says what happened and he didn't
reply she was working away at the video
screens have you tried the radio yet no
well she cried exasperated by his
silence do you know what's going on
Revolution he said how do you know when
a revolution is actually taking place
well part of it is that people tell you
that it is a revolution and A revolution
is something different than just a
conflict different than just a change
different than just even a Revolt or a
riot it means a fundamental breaking
with older ways and structures and
usually a lot of fighting and conflict
and fog of War until some new
configuration comes about and in in this
um one we also see Revolution being
invoked as well in in green Mars and
they you know they say that this is
going to be a new kind of configuration
as well so here in phase change when the
second Martian Revolution began the
first Martian Revolution happens in Red
Mars and it's got devastating effects
Nadia was in the upper Canyon of
shalbont of Alice north of menares in
the sense one could say that she started
it and how so
well because of some political
discussions that are going on but
revolutions also take an awful lot of
preparation both in terms of factors
that human beings don't really control
as such and in terms of planning in
terms of coordination and that is what
takes place so let's talk about the very
first Revolution and there's there's a
few things that we can bring up I'm not
going to get into it in super detail
here but we find that
um here's in in guns under the table
right Chalmers Frank Chalmers is
interviewing prisoners this is as the
revolution has First beginning who are
they revolting against the occupying
forces sent by Earth who are bossing
people around who are trying to keep the
Martians down so Chalmers interviewed
some of the prisoners over their room
videos two or three at a time he says
you see how easy it was to detain you
that's the way it'll be all over the
life support systems are so fragile that
they're impossible to defend even on
Earth Advanced military technology makes
a police state much more possible to
implement than ever before but here it's
absurdly easy
well you got us when it was easiest
reply to man in his 60s which was smart
once we get free I'd like to see you
catch us at that point your life support
system is as vulnerable to us as ours is
to you and yours is more vulnerable and
then he's you know they're arguing about
uh 1776 and you know Chalmers says you
and your friends are trying to live out
some kind of fantasy Rebellion some kind
of sci-fi 1776. Frontiersman throwing
off the Yoke of tyranny but it isn't
like that here the analogies are all
wrong and deceptively wrong because they
mask the reality the true nature of our
dependence and their might they keep you
from seeing that it's a fantasy a little
bit later one of them says it's more
metaphor than an analogy anyway there's
differences but we intend to respond to
that creativity we won't be hefting
muskets over rock walls to take pot
shots at you
and they you know they go on and the man
says I suppose the real question is will
we have a Lincoln will we have somebody
will we have people that can
coalesce movements around them and that
does kind of happen now one of the
catastrophic events that is part of the
Revolution against the occupying forces
is breaking the cable actually not
breaking the cable but unmooring the
cable from its top in the space elevator
and this cable is incredibly thick heavy
and will devastate Mars itself
he says we separated the cable from
Clark that's what we did the cable is on
its way down and they're asked well
what's going to happen with this
sax says it's falling we have the
figures of The Descent if you want them
it's pretty complex
and then you know he says I can't
believe it this is Simon the impact's
going to kill a lot of people
one of the people replies probably not
and those it kill it does kill will
mostly be U.N police who've been using
the elevator to get down and kill people
here on the ground
and the cable does in fact come down and
it like smashes up the entire equator
right
um
so well not exactly the equator they say
the cable is seven thirty seven thousand
kilometers long and the circumference at
the equator is 21
000. it's going to go around at least
twice and then where is it actually
going to fall well we'll know when it
actually does Fall and when it when it
hits all that mass disrupts the Martian
landscape and that is the the crisis in
uh the the early years later on we see
that the Martians as a complex society
are evolving there is this great
discussion in the section of green Mars
called tarakat
at first it had been so strange the ese
had done incredible things while the
first hundred had squabbled fought
fissioned all over the planet started a
war and were now deader in hiding the
first group of Japanese settlers the 240
who founded uh sabishi just seven years
after the first hundred arrived stayed
right next to their Landing site and
built a city they absorbed all the
changes that had followed including the
location of a mole hole right next to
their town they had simply taken over
the Dig and used the tailings for their
construction materials when the
thickening atmosphere made it possible
they guarded the surrounding terrain
which was Rocky and high not an easy
land in the catastrophes of 2061 the
falling of the cable they'd never moved
and considered neutral had been left
alone by the transnationals in that
Solitude they'd taken the excavated
rocks and build it into long snaking
Mounds all shot through with tunnels and
rooms ready to hide people from the
South thus they had invented the demimon
the most sophisticated and complex
society on Mars full of people who
passed each other on the street like
strangers but met at night in rooms to
talk and make music and make love and
even the people not part of the
underworld were interesting because the
ISE had started a university the
University of Mars where many of the
students perhaps a third of the total
were young and Martian born and whether
these young natives were surface world
or underground in origin they recognized
each other without the slightest
difficulty as people at home in a
million subtle ways in ways no Terran
Bourne ever could be so they talked and
made music and made love and naturally
quite a few of the surface natives were
thus initiated into knowledge of the
underground until it began to seem as if
the natives knew all and were natural
allies
much later towards the the last part of
it
we have this
discussion here of what's going on
Praxis and now the the Earth is in chaos
and that is what allows the second
Martian Revolution to happen and that
chaos is a war that's encompassing the
globe of the Haves and the have-nots
being at each other's throats the
multinational organizations against a
lot of the other remaining countries and
indeed religious fundamentalists who
also hate each other but hate the
corporations even more and then there is
an environmental catastrophe
sea levels rise incredibly and not
because of global warming just by itself
but because of volcanic eruptions which
result in a lot of the Antarctic ice
shelf going into the ocean now they're
getting their information
Nadia kept her wrist pad in contact with
either Da Vinci or the free Mars safe
house and Burrows and as they slid on
she watched both the car screen and her
wrist taking in simultaneous bursts of
information
Praxis was sending up continuous reports
on the Terran situation which was
confused but not incoherent or opaque as
it had been in 61.
for one thing Praxis was keeping them
informed for another much of the current
activity on Earth was devoted to moving
the coastal populations out of the reach
of the floods which so far were like
very high tides as Sac said they would
be the meta natural side was still being
played out in the form of surgical
strikes and decapitation coups Commando
raids and counter raids on various
corporate compounds and headquarters
combined with legal actions and PR of
All Sorts including suits and counter
suits finally introduced to the world
Court
but these strategic raids and Maneuvers
were much reduced in the face of the
global flood and even at their worst
video of exploding compounds airplane
crash sites stretches of roads
craterized by the bombing of passing
limousines they were infinitely better
than any kind of escalating War which in
biological form could kill Millions
as it became clear unfortunately with a
shocking report from Indonesia that came
over the car's screen a radical
Liberation group from East Timor model
on Peru's shining path had poisoned the
island of java with a yet unidentified
plague so that with the travails of the
flooding there they were losing hundreds
of thousands to disease so this is all
happening on Earth and this is allowing
something else to take place the
Martians have organized and the nergal
gives a speech that's quite important
and actually quite rather impressive
right nergal says
um
our bodies are made of atoms that until
recently were part of the regolith we
are Martian through and through we are
living pieces of Mars we are human
beings who have made a permanent
biological commitment to this planet it
is our home and we can never go back now
as for those of us who were born on
Earth well there are different kinds
aren't there when people move to a new
place some intend to stay and make it
their new home and we call those
settlers others come to work for a while
then go back where they came from and we
call those visitors or colonists now
Natives and settlers are natural allies
after all natives are no more than the
children of earlier settlers this is
home to all of us together as for
visitors there is room on Mars for them
too when we say now notice this
important slogan Mars is free we are not
saying terrans can no longer come here
not at all we're children of Earth One
Way or Another it is our mother world
and we're happy to help it in every way
we can but the obvious fact nurgle went
on is that what happens here on Mars
should not be decided by colonists or by
anyone back on Earth
a simple statement of our desire for
self-determination our natural right the
driving force of human nature we are not
a colony and we won't be treated as one
there is no such thing as a colony
anymore we are a free Mars now that's a
great slogan well you know oh you know
we're going to rise up against the
oppressors a revolution has to involve
more than that what does nirgo say after
that
what we intend to do now
as free martians is to welcome every
Terran who wants to come to us whether
to live here for a time and then go back
or else to settle here permanently we
intend also to do everything we can to
help earth and its current environmental
crisis we have some expertise with
flooding and we can help
but this help from now on will no longer
come mediated by The Meta Nationals
exacting their profits from the exchange
it will come as a free gift
it will benefit the people of Earth more
than anything that could be extracted
from us as a colony this is true in the
strict literal sense of the amount of
resources and work that will be
transferred from Mars to Earth and so we
hope and trust that everyone on both
worlds will welcome the emergence of a
free Mars and that is it that is the you
know culmination and the articulation
now of a revolution that is going to
take place a second revolution on Mars
and the question is you know can they
actually pull this off or not and that's
where the book is actually ending in
uncertainty about that a revolution that
is now a second revolution that is
taking place which will allow the
originally Earth people now martians to
decide their own destiny and it doesn't
happen because of like you know a grand
intricate plan it requires lots and lots
of coordination of many disparate
elements who want to see a better future
for themselves and for their progeny so
that's where we're going to leave off
with this first installation of this
fascinating rich and so well researched
and developed and outlined sketched out
however you want to put it Trilogy red
Mars green Mars blue Mars blue Mars we
will get to in the next session and
we'll certainly be coming back to red
and green Mars in the process so I hope
you can join us next time for that
continuation of this but that brings
this one to a hopefully successful close
thank you
foreign